I'm gonna show you something beautiful,
everyone sleep for mercy,
must protect but you don't want it to change.
Your all puppets
tangled in
strings
It's the end, the end of the path that I started us on.
Nothing lasts forever.
There are no strings on me.
Hey Youtubers its Charlie so the Age of Ultron trailer totally leaked last night
obviously everyone has pretty much seen
it Marvel did the only logical thing
and officially released it on their
channel so it's totally clear for me to post now.
So this will be a breakdown of the
trailer which is basically an expanded
version of the Comic-Con trailer.
In an explanation of how this is going
to lead in Captain America 3
in the civil war story line that
everyone's been talking about so
starting up we just see a regular
cityscape.
This is obviously before Ultron goes
crazy on everyone.
And here the fun starts
so this is basically just a repeat of what
we saw in the first Avengers movie
everything goes crazy the vendors are
called in to help.
This melting effect, this hand here
is obviously Ultron forging himself a
new body.
One other really cool thing
that Joss Whedon said he would be honoring
is the fact that Ultron gets better, he evolves himself.
during San Diego Comic-Con they even
showed up Ultron mark 1.
It just looks like a modified Iron Man
suit obviously the final version of Ultron looks
way, way scarier, much cooler too.  In the comics Ultron eventually
forges himself an Adamantium body, it is
basically
tries to make himself as indestructible as
possible.  Here we start to see The Avengers
looking like they're getting the crap beaten out of them.
just like New York all over again.
Captain America; obviously wearing his
shiny new suit
this one actually looks way way, better it's
basically a riff on the classic suit
which obviously was put on a Winter Soldier.
Hawkeye who was notably cut out of Winter Soldier, he actually did have a cameo in
that movie but they cut his part out because the movie was so long.
Supposedly Jeremy Renner said he's up
for a solo movie.
But that doesn't mean that they're gonna
do it anytime soon,
Thor here is actually in this movie living on
earth, Bill explained the drama that's
going on in Asguard and where Odin is and
what's going on with Loki during the
third Thor movie.
That's gonna be in phase 3 its one of the
confirmed phase three movies.
he's a pretty pornographic shot of the
Quinjet, it just looks totally badass.
This is clearly after a big battle if you
haven't read the comic Age of Ultron
it's different from what the movie's
gonna be
if not the same plot, but it basically
shows the Avengers getting their asses
handed to them.
So we zoom in on Mark Ruffalo and he actually said some interesting things about
what's going on with the Hulk in this
movie, he said that the address the fact
that the green guy is just as afraid of Banner
as Banner is of the green guy which is
really interesting idea
the idea that the Hulk is afraid a Bruce
Banner.  You could almost think this as like a
minor Hulk movie.
this is an Ultron Mark 1, this is more
like Mark 2.
but he busts in on an Avengers party, this
is basically part
of the Comic-Con footage they showed off this, right here though this is part of
Ultron Mark 1
see it basically looks like a modified
Stark suit.  Tony Stark basically plugs
his modified
AI into one of his suits, and its not
Jarvis
even though the vision is basically where Jarvis comes from
modified Jarvis that is if not straight up
Jarvis
its something a little bit different, very
interesting. Obviously were not going to see that
in the first trailer.
This is basically the moment where Ultron
turns against them though,
and comes to the realization that
humanity needs to be wiped out.
The funny thing is that
like a lot a robots, like Cylons for instance
Ultron is really true to his
programming
He is programmed to make the world a better, but he determines that humans are a
cancer on the Earth.
and so humans need to go.  Here's the new Ironman suit,
looks totally badass, obviously looks
like a modified version of the Ultron
Mark 1 that we just saw
This is one of the truckers labs, since
Winter Soldier the Avengers have been
traveling all over the world
trying to clean up all these Hydra
bases, that's why they create Ultron,
because there is to many of them to all get, even with their powers.
I know everyone's wondering whether or
not the mind jem is in Loki's staff
which the trucker labs has
that has been confirmed it is the best
rumor so far
so you get some conflict all over the
world so what happens is the basically
splits the Avengers focus
all over the world so it's not one
attack in one place
Banner freaking out in the woods it wouldn't be an Avengers movie if it weren't for Banner
freaking out somewhere.
this is Black Widow in the ruins of S.H.I.E.L.D if you remember this is actually one of
the rooms that they were in during Winter
Soldier
we don't see this is obviously it looks
very sinister so I'm guessing it's one
of the villains
Andy Circus is actually in the movie we
don't know who he is playing so
it might be associated with or maybe a
trucker scene.
Here is Ultron, in his final form in all its glory.  The fact that Quiksilver
and Scarlet Witch are standing near him says a lot they're obviously like the next step
in human evolution
so that's a big point of contention
especially with the Civil War idea on the
horizon
a lot of people are speculating that the
Age of Miracles so to speak
is what inspires the Civil War conflict
but the idea that
people need to register their powers
just because they start getting so crazy
here's some of the Ultron robots, these are the ones he's gonna be sending all over the
earth
here's another shot of Ultron Mark 1.
This is actually the prop they brought to
Comic-Con it was really cool
it was literally this prop you're
looking at right here Nick Fury back in
action
tell ya since the Sam Jackson remember
after Winter Soldier he basically went
off the grid
just to hunt Hydra people down.  Obviously Scarlet Witch screaming here is a bit of an
easter egg for No More Mutants in the
House of Them
that's not really what the movie is
doing the there not going to do House of Them type
stuff
her powers don't work exactly that way,
and the Hulk buster
so this is actually gonna be really awesome I know everybody was waiting for this
hope versus the Avengers isn't gonna be too crazy in this movie.
The funny thing that Joss Whedon said about the Hulk buster armor though
it came after he stopped reading the
comics like he's big comic book fan of course
he always has it's just that the Hulk buster armor appeared in the comics
after he started working in Hollywood so
he just didn't have the time to keep up
every week
this is Black Widows new motorcycle, it is
one of the most badass motorcycles we've
ever seen
here's actually a better shot of it, I just
love the idea that she drops out of a
moving Quinjet
here we get some nice shots of Quicksilver and Scarlet Witches powers
and here he is Andy Circus we don't
really know anything about his villain
other than he is a villian
like he's definitely a very bad person in this
movie so this is actually really
interesting scene
Black Widow with Banner as the hawk
there's a lotta rumors
that he's going to have some sorta
implied relationship with her in the
movie
they have some sort of shit going but
they haven't consummated there
relationship because banners afraid of
going Hulk
mid sex you can choose whether not to
believe that it is just a rumor right now
but supposedly Black Widow will be
having some sorta romance with Bruce
Banner
and here's the conflict so obviously everyone was talking about civil war
that means the Avengers have to start
fighting, this really does support that idea
but Thor is probably just chocking Tony
Stark out because of what happens with
Ultron
like its probably right after Ultron rebels.
Of course he's the AI genius
so everyone's totally gonna blame him
here's some more Hulk buster porn
totally awesome, Im going to rewatch that three or four thousand times.
and here's the big WTF this is actually in the comic-con trailer
Captain America shield is broken so in
the movie universe they call it Vibranium
obviously in the comics is Adamantium
but the x-men universe talks rights
you know yada yada yada
essentially this is the hardest metal
on earth so that's why this is such a big
deal
the reason is broken is because Ultron
forges
a new body for himself out of that same
metal and here he is
so when Ultron is talking about strings in
this trailer he's talking about
obviously control like Tony Stark:
controlling him like a puppet
which isn't happening anymore any more, and he's talking about the strings the connect
people emotionally
so he's a robot he doesn't feel emotion
Whedon called him something of an insane
robot
so I do kinda wonder if he develops a
certain personality
be been an emotion definitely
personality. So really
what this trailer does just take us up
to the o-shit moment
like Ultron strikes and starts crushing
everyone, everything's in chaos
during comic-con the way the movie was
explained is that
a lot of his is about the good in the
bad child of Tony Stark
obviously the bad child being Ultron, the good child being division
we've already seen a bit of a teaser form in
this promo art here this is what he looks like
obviously you know he's going to look a little bit
different in CG, just a little better that
is
Paul Betteny will be playing him in full on mo-cap
so he will move like a human, obviously as will Ultron, like
this is what Ultron looks like behind the
scenes when they're filming
James Spader actually made some jokes
about trying to play an eight-foot tall
robot verses a human
it was funny to watch interviews with
really amazing actors that don't
normally do genre stuff like this,
They always have this really funny fresh
perspective on it like it's all very
weird
and awesome to them like playing in
someone else's sandbox so just explain
the Civil War stuff is going on
obviously after this movie it's implied
the Avengers are gonna be fractured they
gonna go their separate ways
Thor is gonna go back to Asguard and that will be
where Thor 3 picks up.
Captain America's gonna go his own way
that's where Captain America 3 picks
up
I have heard a lot of West Coast
Avengers rumors obviously that's where
Captain America forms his
own Avengers team and it becomes West
Coast Avengers the rumor is the Captain
America 3
is going to feature Secret
Avengers there's gonna do something like
that
basically the Captain America: with his own
team have heroes away from Tony Stark
but because all these new people start
manifesting powers
like Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
supposedly the government gets involved
because it's become such a global
problem
Tony Stark take their side natually
being a government
contractor and you have civil war if you
haven't read the comics
totally check it out it's an awesome story
line it's possible they could just like
lead that over and Avengers 3 but the
rumors that
Avengers 3 is gonna be a complete BT
movie
like it won't feature the a-list main
Avengers so yes the Marvelverse is gonna be
turning to complete chaos but it's going
to be a lot of fun
obviously they just want to expand things so
they do need to rely on their
A player's quite as much I think it's a
good way to ensure that everyone doesn't
start suffering from Avengers
fatigue any gives the potential
directors obviously the Russo brothers
who probably are going to be taking over Avengers 3
some fresh faces to work with like I
said it's all good thing
now though using this in all its glory
they're going to start posting more updates so I
will be doing more Avengers videos as we
go forward
be sure to subscribe to get everything
if you have any special request for
bonus videos let me know
My next avengers video is going to be my top 5 Ultron stories so I'll try to
post that tomorrow
right now you can click here to get that
and you can click here to learn all about
the Captain America 3: Civil War
drama
Thank You so much for watching so lets all high five and rewatch that trailer